[Music]
in philip k dick's
novel the android's dream of electric
sheep one of the important characters is
this fellow john isadore who is
classified as a special and the way that
dick
structures the book
it's always centered on a particular
character in the majority of the
chapters it's rick deckard the main
character of the entire novel but
isadore is the other character
that dick does this with so even though
there's characters that are very
important to the story like for example
rachel rosen she doesn't get the same
sort of treatment that isidore does and
by comparison to rick who's at least
not a special and you know is fairly
astute pretty good at his job isadore
represents a different kind of humanity
and we should begin
in chapter two at the very beginning
there's some exposition
about the world that they're living in
this setting in which most of the
animals have died off because of
radioactive
dust and
it goes on and says loitering on earth
potentially meant finding oneself
abruptly classified as biologically
unacceptable a menace to the pristine
heredity of the race once pegged
as special a citizen even if accepting
sterilization
dropped out of history he ceased in
effect to be part of mankind and yet
persons here and there declined to
migrate that even to those involved
constituted a perplexing
irrationality logically every regular
should have emigrated all
ready and you know so why are people
staying there on earth in any case
thousands of individuals remain most of
them constellated in urban areas where
they could physically see one another
take heart at their mutual presence
those appeared to be the relatively
sane ones like rick deckard and his wife
in a dubious addition to them occasional
peculiar entities remained in the
virtually
abandoned
suburbs john isadore being yammered at
by the television set in his living room
as he shaved in the bathroom was one of
these so we're learning a lot already
isidore himself has been classified
as a special which means that he's got
distorted genes he's not supposed to
breed he's not supposed to go off world
and things are a little bit worse for
him in that he has
recently
failed a very important test
so john isadore is watching tv and he
thinks
you know
worry has gone away for me without
having to emigrate he had been a special
now for over a year
not merely in regard to the distorted
genes he carried worse still he'd failed
to pass the minimum
mental
faculties test which made him in popular
parlance a chicken head a derogatory
term upon him the contempt of three
planets descended earth mars and perhaps
you know another one in the solar system
however despite this he survived so
he's he's stuck on earth he can't
emigrate he's living in a
apartment building way out in the
suburbs by himself and
you know he's in kind of
a
if not rough but we could call it
stagnant spot but he can
hold a job and this is important for
his life
and you know for
engaging with other human beings like it
says here he had a job driving a pickup
and delivery truck for a
false animal repair firm the van ness
pet hospital and his gloomy gothic boss
hannibal sloat accepted him as human and
this he appreciated
mr sloat is is you know treating him as
if being a special
is not quite so special although he's
going to call him a chicken head a
little bit
later on
and so you know this is in in already in
chapter two we've got this character
introduced then
we could look immediately if we were
following uh sequentially at his
engagement with the first android that
he encounters chris stratton who's going
to claim
first that she's actually rachel rosen
but we'll look at that in a bit let's
think about this van
van ness pet hospital
and the scene
that we encounter so he
picks up
a the first male functioning animal for
the day an electric cat
it lay in the plastic dust proof
carrying cage at the rear of the truck
and panted erratically you'd almost
think it's real isidore observed as he
headed back to the van
ness pet hospital that carefully
misnamed little enterprise which barely
existed in the tough competitive field
of false animal repair so we should
pause on this for a moment
human beings
value having animals animals are
expensive and rare and as we see with
rick decker talking about his
first sheep and then the electric sheep
that he replaced it with animals are
pretty subject to getting themselves
into illness and
death and all sorts of
problems so a lot of people have false
animals but they don't want to reveal
that they're fake that they're electric
so
instead they they have this
service come and pick them up take them
back to the shop do whatever needs to be
done you know recalibrate things change
the batteries and stuff like that
and so we've got this
what seems to be at first a it's
described as false and electrical
cat
but it's not
really
that way and isidore is talking to the
cat he says can you hang on till we
reach the shop i'll recharge you while
we're on route and he tries to find the
place where the charger would be
says
it would have fooled me as he groped
within the irzot stomach fur for the
concealed control panel plus the quick
charge battery terminals he could find
neither nor could he search very long
the mechanism had almost failed the cat
has you know got bubbles coming out of
its mouth and is is you know whining and
stuff like that and then the the false
cat ceases functioning so evidently the
short if that was what ailed the thing
had finished off the power supply and
basic drive
train anything so that's going to run
into some money so he drives there and
he drops the
cat off with hannibal's float and milt
and sloat says what do you got there he
says a cat with a short in his power
supply and sloth says why show it to me
take it down in the shop to milt but he
opens it up and then he's examining it
and he says
this isn't a fake cat this is a real cat
and then he says
to milt
the chicken had brought it in and milt
says if it was still alive we could take
it to
a real
uh
animal vet i wonder what it's worth and
isidor says doesn't your insurance cover
this and sloth says yeah the insurance
covers this that's that's not the point
don't you understand
he says it's the waste that gets me the
loss of one more living creature
couldn't you tell
isidore didn't you
notice the difference
is
i thought it was a really good job so
good it fooled me i mean it seemed alive
and a job that good and then milt says
i don't think isadore can actually tell
the difference to him they're all alive
false animals included he probably tried
to save it what did you do try to
recharge its battery or locate a short
in it
and um you know this is kind of telling
us something about isidore himself
he
feels
empathy towards
all sorts of living things and he can't
tell the difference effectively between
artificial life
fake life electric life
later on android life
and
genuine living organic animals
milt goes on and he says it probably was
so far gone it wouldn't have made any
difference anyhow let the chicken head
off the hook and you notice that he's
also using this term he's got a point
these fakes are beginning to be darn
near real what with these disease
circuits they're building into the new
ones and living animals do die that's
one of the risks in owning them we're
not used to it because all we see is
fakes and sloth says the god damn waste
and then
isadora says according to mercer all
life returns the cycle is complete for
animals too i mean we all ascend with
him die and then slot says
tell that to the guy who owned the cat
now this is an offhand remark but
isidore is not good at picking up the
difference between those and serious
remarks and he says you're not going to
make me make the video call
and slot and milt go back and forth
about this and slo in fact makes isidore
call up the
owner
the
pilsens and mrs pilsen described as a
mitchell urapaisha somewhat careful
looking woman who wore her hair in a
tight bun
and
they go back and forth and
isidore says oh you know your cat has
died
[Music]
and then he starts going off script a
little bit says you know we'll replace
it and slot says we'll give them a check
isadora says we'll we'll personally pick
out the replacement cat
for you
having started a conversation which he
could not endure he discovered himself
unable to get out what he was saying
possessed an intrinsic logic which he
had no means of halting it had to grind
to its own conclusion both
mr sloat and milt borogrove stared at
him as he rattled on just give us the
specifications of the cat you desire so
he's he's like now off you know making
decisions for the company and pretty
soon the owner is going to have to
intervene but it is also sort of a
affirming process for isidore to engage
in he doesn't think he's up to it and he
he is up to it
so it's kind of an interesting uh
passage there
let's jump into talking about the
androids now so the first one that he
meets is chris stratton and this is
happening
back earlier
in
chapter six he
hears a tv set in his apartment building
and he said wow somebody else is here so
he goes to visit
and what we see is a
fragmented and misaligned shrinking
figure a girl who cringed and slunk away
and yet held onto the door as if her
physical support fear had made her seem
ill it distorted her body lines made it
appear as if someone had broken her and
then with malice patched her together
badly her eyes enormous glazed over
fixedly as she attempted to smile
isadora says you thought no one lived in
this building you thought it was
abandoned the girl says yes and then
isidore says it's good to have neighbors
heck until you came along i didn't have
any and that was no fun god knew and she
says you're the only one in this
building and they they talk back and
forth he's um you know trying to explain
to her the apartment building the notion
of kipple or entropy
that fills up all these things how kind
of scary it is to be in a
place all by
yourself and then you know they have
this interesting exchange
where she first tells him when he you
know tells her his name
that her name is rachel rosen and then
she of course has to take it back when
he points out you know that the rosen
corporation and she says my name is
chris stratton
you better address me as miss stratton
because we don't really know each other
in chapter 13 we return to
discussions between them
and she tells him that she is actually
being
hunted by these bounty hunters she says
that a bounty hunter is a professional
murderer who's been given a list of
those he's supposed to kill he's paid a
sum a thousand dollars is the going rate
i understand for each he gets
usually he has a contract with the city
and
so
she says um
he has incentive he enjoys it and
isadore says i think you're mistaken
never in his life had he heard of such a
thing he says it's not in accord with
present-day mercerian ethics all life is
one no man is an island as shakespeare
said in olden times and she says john
dunn
and then isidore says that's worse than
anything i ever heard of can't you call
the police i mean the irony of course
here is
the police are the bounty hunters or at
least a certain subclass of them so no
of course she can't call the police
because she is being hunted by the
police
and he says and they're after you
they're apt to come here and kill you no
wonder you're scared and don't want to
see anybody but he thought it must be a
delusion she must be psychotic with
delusions of persecution maybe from
brain damage due to the dust maybe she's
special and then he's very chivalrous he
says i'll get them first i'll get a
permit for a laser beam and i'll i'll
kill them before they they get you and
she's you know rather
skeptical
of that he also tries to feed her
and you know that's
they don't really need to eat so it's
not much of a
a exchange and then the babies arrive
roy and irmgard beatty two more people
uh prissy's friends
and they start having some discussions
about well what should they do
priss herself is kind of a snob right as
irmgard tells her uh and she doesn't
want to move in with isidore because
he's a chicken head and she she holds
that in contempt but the babies suggest
no no you really should and we'll all
actually move in
uh together
and then um
we we find out that
uh
there's a whole bunch of
other things that are going on they
begin talking about um the bounty
hunters some more
and who's been killed who's in the
hospital
how things worked
and again
isidore is starting to suspect
something and
chris is going to tell isidore for a
short time roy beatty is as crazy as i
am our trip was between a mental
hospital on the east coast and here
we're all schizophrenic with defective
emotional lives flattening of affect
it's called and we have group
hallucinations isidore is very relieved
he says i didn't think it was true and
she says well why didn't you and he says
things like that don't happen the
government never kills anybody for any
crime and mercerism and then we get some
interesting discussion here so she says
chris says
you see if you're not human it's all
different
and um
isidore says well that's not true even
animals even eels and gophers and snakes
and spiders are sacred
and she says so it can't be a cannon as
you say even animals are protected by
law all life everything organic that
wriggles or squirms or burrows or flies
or swarms or lays eggs and roy beatty
comes in and says
insects are especially sacrosanct now
what life isn't sacrosanct
and red life right
animals are human beings are
and uh
isidore starts to
piece together that they are actually
androids
that he says you're androids but he
didn't care it made no difference to him
i see why they want to kill you actually
you're not alive everything made sense
to him now the bounty hunter the killing
of their friends the trip to earth
and
you know
isidore says you're intellectual
you think abstractly and you don't i
wish i had an iq like you then i could
pass the test i wouldn't be a chicken
head i think you're very superior i
could learn a lot from you
and pris says he doesn't understand yet
how he got off of mars what we did there
and uh irmgard says i don't think we
have to worry about mr isidore
they don't treat him very well either as
he said and what we did on mars he isn't
interested in he knows us and likes us
and an emotional acceptance like that
it's everything to him it's hard for us
to grasp that but it's true
and she says
isidore you realize you could turn us in
and get a lot of money right
and she says to roy see he realizes that
but he wouldn't say anything
roy says if he was an android he'd turn
us in you know in in a heartbeat
actually tomorrow morning and so isadore
has you know worked out a kind of
arrangement with these androids and
they're cool with him and he's cool with
them until
something happens
it's not the revelation that on part of
buster friendly that mercerism is a fake
is a swindle and all that
it's rather what they do
with a spider
and what this shows
is the lack of empathy right
pris says i've never seen a spider
all those legs why does it need so many
legs j.r and isidor says that's the way
spiders are and then pris says you know
what i think j.r
i think it doesn't need all those legs
eight irimgard beatty said why couldn't
it get by on four cut four off and c and
then a weird terror
strikes isidore he's now realizing what
these androids are
capable of they lack empathy towards
other life and they
have a mixture of curiosity
and cruelty that is going to be taken
out on this poor spider whose legs they
sniff off and then you know try to burn
in order to make move
and he ends up taking the spider and
drowning it now he also has an
interesting interlude with mercer where
mercer is going to he ascends to the
tomb world mercer's there
gives him the spider back he comes back
to the world of you know
the
apartment building
and then um he meets up with the bounty
hunter he's out in the hallway
and he puts the spider down
um
here we go
he deposited the spider he experienced
its wavering progress as it departed his
hand well that was that he straightened
up
and then a flashlight appears the man
holding the flashlight said what did you
do
i put down a spider so it could get away
and they have a brief exchange and uh
isidore says if i took it back up to the
apartment she'd cut it apart again bit
by bit to see what it did and the man
says androids do that he shows his badge
and he says you know are they up there
the three
and isidore won't go
up to help him out
and so you know that is almost the end
after rick kills the remaining three
androids in isidore's apartment
isidore says
i'm leaving this building i'm going to
live deeper in town where there's more
people rick says i think there's a
vacant apartment in my building and
isidore says i don't want to live
near you
and rick says go outside or upstairs
don't stay in here
the special floundered not knowing what
to do a variety of mute expressions
crossed his face then turning a shuffle
out of the apartment
leaving rick alone and that is the last
that we see of john isidor but he's been
a very important
character
for
interacting with the androids and giving
us a sense about what life is like
for somebody who isn't you know higher
up in the social hierarchy like a bounty
hunter but somebody who is indeed
a special so
interesting and uh
quite central character without being
the main character of the work
you